well I think that term in terms of
political forces India since veo
destined for a long era of coalition
governance the last two governments each
were made up of coalition to 20-yard
parties and and that seems with the
direction Indian politics you are a
couple of big national parties there the
Congress party and the the the more
hindu inclined BJP party have each got
about a third of the seats and slightly
less than a third of the vote and then
the remaining third is split up amongst
as many as almost 40 parties in the
parliament or some which have one or two
members from which it therefore exercise
a very influenced when coalition
building takes place I think that's
likely to be the direction of Indian
politics I'm not thrilled about it one
could argue that it promotes
conciliation and cooperation but on the
negative side it also means that
governments are vulnerable to the rise
and fall of political temperatures and
that a executive unlike the u.s. it
can't just be elected to execute to go
out and change things the better it's
constantly going to have to look over
its political shoulder at the the the
tastes and wishes and demands of each of
its many coalition members and that I
think is a pity having said that the
future economic progress of India looks
very promising today as I speak to in
2007 we're talking about nine point five
percent economic growth for GDP and if
that continues we're looking at not only
pulling more people out of poverty that
any country in the world of bar in China
has ever done human history we're also
talking about creating a society that's
full of people the most amazing talent
creative energy and youthfulness
fifty-four percent of the Indian
population is under 25 that's that's
five hundred and fifty million people
and these people are going to be growing
up and being at their productive best
when many parts of the world
particularly Europe and China will be
aging so India could have an extremely
important part to play in the 21st
century
you